washington d.c has ended its overnight
curfew it was imposed as large protests
led president trump
to threaten military action against
demonstrators
he is rejecting the newest criticism
from former advisers
and fellow republicans who say his
response was in their words
out of line wishing has more on this
story from the white house
as protests across the nation's capital
stayed peaceful
about 700 soldiers stationed outside
washington d.c
who were on alert in case demonstrations
turned violent started heading home to
north carolina
but damage is already done from law
enforcement using force to clear a calm
demonstration on monday
republican senator lisa murkowski said
she doesn't know if she can support
president trump
i am struggling with it i have struggled
with it for a long time
and that she was thankful for former
secretary of defense general james
mattis's statement
that slammed the president for
militarizing the response to protests
and accused him of dividing the country
i thought general mattis's words
were true and honest and necessary
and overdue mr trump vowed to campaign
against murkowski by supporting
any candidate good or bad who has a
pulse
after he lashed out at mattis claiming
he fired him in 2018.
general john kelly chief of staff at the
time told the washington post
the president did not fire him he did
not ask for his resignation
the president has clearly forgotten how
it actually happened or
is confused on twitter president trump
said he did not tell kelly about firing
mattis
because he was not in my inner circle
that many african-americans
lacked confidence in our american
criminal justice system attorney general
bill barr
defended the administration's response
to protests
but also vowed to improve police
relations with african americans
later today president trump is scheduled
to head to maine to visit a company that
manufactures
coven 19 testing swabs earlier this week
the governor
told him that she was worried the trip
may cause security problems the
president told her
a tremendous crowd is showing up but
that most of the people
like him anthony
weisha thank you